A third of new arrivals
die within three years,
while their masters grow
rich and build grand
mansions overlooking the
damned.
The central square in the
image must be the
master's house.
The rectangular
structures we saw in the
ground, that must be the
barrack blocks to
accommodate the slaves.
This would be a central
mill here, where the cane
was crushed and the
juice would come down
into refining furnaces.
Accounts of sugar boiling
houses depict a steaming
vision of hell, where
copper cauldrons of raw
syrup bubble at 240°F.
It would have been
incredibly hot.
Smoke would have been
toxic and a hellhole down
in this. In this mill.